after an endless series of delays and
re-shoot Aquaman will get his second
solo film just in time for Christmas
before you dive in here's what you need
to know before its Premiere Aquaman in
the lost kingdom is slated for release
on December 22nd 2023 fans who have been
following the DC extended universe will
know that lost kingdom suffered some
drastic delays due to the shakeup that
occurred following the Warner Brothers
Discovery merger the movie was initially
scheduled to be released on December
16th 2022 before being moved back to
March 17th 2023 the film was moved yet
again to December 25th 2023 and then to
December 20th finally Warner Brothers
decided to move the film one more time
to December 22nd which is where it'll
hopefully stay put December will be a
big month for the studio as they're
releasing Wonka Aquaman and The Color
Purple back to back to back will their
three-pronged Play Bring In The Box
Office dollars the movies likely won't
be competing for the same audiences so
if fans are in the mood for a superhero
action during the holidays the last
Kingdom might farewell against its
December competition as fans might
recall the first Aquaman saw our hero
defeat his half brother or and take over
his king of Atlantis according to the
official synopsis Aquaman's new Reign
comes under attack after his old enemy
Black Manta arrives in Atlantis seeking
Revenge this time though the villain has
the power of the black Trident which
unleashes a devastating and evil power
following the Return of Black Manta
Aquaman is forced to team up with his
imprisoned brother as the two tried
desperately to save their family's
Kingdom and the world from the
destructive power of the black Trident
with these two brothers bickering it's
sure to be a blast as they battle all
sorts of aquatic enemies to protect
their home
World brother hire do not call me
brother Aquaman and the lost kingdom
Stars Jason Mamoa as the Atlantean King
who also goes by the name of Arthur
Curry yaha Abdul matin II and Patrick
Wilson reprised their roles from the
first film as well with tamura Morrison
and Nicole Kidman also returning to play
Tom Curry and Atlanta also returning to
the cast is Amber herd who reprises her
role as the Atlantean Warrior mea her
herd's involvement with the film
continues to be a source of heavy
controversy among online fans with many
still petitioning for her removal from
Aquaman after she lost a civil
defamation verdict against Johnny Depp
in 2022 herd is joined by action star
Dolph lungren who is said to appear in
the film as mea's father King nerus when
the original Aquaman swam into theaters
back in 2018 the undersea Adventure
earned a staggering 1.14 billion dollar
which made it the fifth highest grossing
movie of the year needless to say Warner
Brothers didn't want to screw around
with success so they brought on the same
filmmaker who sailed the original movie
to box office Glory James Juan In
addition to helming both Aquaman movies
Juan is no stranger to Action Fair as he
directed both Furious 7 and death
sentence of course most movie goers
probably associate Juan with the horror
genre as he also directed saw The
Conjuring and Insidious among other
creepy films and evidently he had his
fair share of horror working on the lost
kingdom as one had to undergo three
separate re-shoot which The Hollywood
Reporter described as almost an
unprecedented number Warner Brothers and
DC have famously undergone some regime
changes over the last few years and
evidently new bosses demanded new angles
on the material despite all the behind
the-scenes drama Juan got it done and
even though multiple people have given
him notes the filmmaker insists the lost
kingdom is still his creation telling
Entertainment Weekly at the end of the
day this is my movie in addition to
bringing back Jason mimoa and James Juan
for the sequel the film also features
the return of screenwriter David Lesley
Johnson McGoldrick a longtime
collaborator of Wands and the writer
behind the original Aquaman film are you
invoking the combat of the Kings call it
whatever you want I call it an ass
whooping aside from Lost Kingdom Johnson
McGoldrick has also written screenplays
for films like Wrath of the Titans and
The Conjuring 2 and television shows
like The Walking Dead early reports
indicated that at least some of the
story for lost kingdom was based on a
pitch that mimoa himself created after
the filming of the first Aquaman however
as of right now it's unclear how much of
that pitch made it into Johnson
mcgoldrick's final script while there
have been a few exceptions here and
there such as the R-rated Zack sniders
Justice League Most DCU movies come
ready to rock with a PG 13 rating after
all it's the sweet spot for Blockbuster
success it's just edgy enough so you
know there's some violence and Mild
cursing but it's tame enough so kids and
teens can watch all the highest grossing
movies are PG-13 and that's also true
for DC titles such as Wonder Woman Man
of Steel and the original Aquaman so it
should come as no surprise that Aquaman
and the lost kingdom will be rated PG-13
The Aquatic Adventure earned that rating
due to sci-fi violence and some language
expect the same sort of content you saw
in the first Aquaman film and chances
are good that you won't be shocked by
anything you see on the screen after the
film's title announcement earlier that
month production for Aquaman in the lost
kingdom began in late June 2021 while
the first film was shot in Australia
Italy and Morocco the lost kingdom began
production in the United Kingdom where
most of the film was shot with so much
of Aquaman and the lost kingdom taking
place underwater it makes sense that the
picture would would be shot at Warner
Brother studios in London something that
fans taking the studio tour confirmed
back in July 2022 though principal
photography had wrapped 6 months earlier
additional re-shoot with Ben Affleck
Batman took place in the summer of 2022
Beyond Europe the lost kingdom spent
some time in the United States
throughout the back half of 2021 Los
Angeles and Hawaiian units shot
additional material with lead Stars
Jason mimoa and Patrick Wilson seen on
set in Malibu on the very last day of
principal
photography most comic book and
superhero movies are generally in
inspired by The Source material so it
shouldn't come as a surprise that
Aquaman in the lost kingdom draws from
those same sources at the end of the
trailer for the movie Warner Brothers
and DC Comics promoted a few graphic
novels that showcase the recent history
of our favorite Atlantean King the
trench and War for the throne are both
stories written by DC scribe Jeff JNS
when he reinvented Aquaman for a modern
audience the third book The drowning was
helmed by Dan Abnet and set during the
DC rebirth era which sought to combine
the traditional DC status quo with
modern stories in a blended Universe the
drown in is also notable due to Arthur's
attempts to make peace between his
undersea people and the surface world of
course these aren't the only Aquaman
stories that likely inspired the lost
kingdom but given that they're being
officially promoted by the film there's
probably a strong
correlation it's no secret that the DC
extended Universe timeline is a bit of a
mess despite starting strong with a
Clear Vision for a more mature take on
the franchise everything after Justice
League feels pretty disjointed not even
Zack Snider's long anticipated
director's cut of Justice League could
fix the DCU leaving its fate up in the
air until James gun and Peter saffron
took over in 2023 and asked it for good
following Man of Steel was Batman versus
Superman dawn of Justice in 2016 which
marked the first tease of Jason mima's
Aquaman and the following year brought
Justice League after that the Atlantean
got his own feature film in 2018 which
is set about a year after steepen wolf
attacked Earth and the Justice League
was formed in the Years following the
DCU opted to highlight characters such
as Shazam Harley Quinn and Peacemaker in
a variety of projects leading into the
2020s taking place around the event of
2022 is black adom and 2023 is Shazam
Fury of the Gods and possibly after the
flash the Aquaman sequel continues
Arthur's story as the DCU closes shop
where Blue Beetle fits into all this we
don't know but we know that the lost
kingdom marks the official end of the
DCU after his brief found footage cameo
in Batman versus Superman dawn of
Justice Jason mimoa made his first
official appearance in 2017's Justice
League when Batman first meets him
Arthur is disillusioned and depressed
having been cast out by his own people
strong man is strong as alone you ever
heard that that's not a saying that's
the opposite of what the saying is yeah
it's only after meeting others like him
and saving the world that he sees the
value in being a hero and a king a year
later Arthur is confronted by mea and
vulco who need his help to save Atlantis
Arthur's half brother or is quickly
running the kingdom into the ground and
aims to declare war on the surface world
this leads to Arthur and mea discovering
the Trident of adlin finding his mother
Atlanta and reclaiming the throne after
defeating or Aquaman ends with Arthur
now ruling as the king of Atlantis
unfortunately Aquaman doesn't appear
much in the DC euu after that he's
mentioned here are there in movies like
Shazam but it wasn't until a cameo in
the season 1 finale of Peacemaker that
mimoa returned to the role alongside
Ezra Miller's flash speaking of Arthur
drunkenly reunites with Barry Allen at
the end of The Flash too which is
fitting given how that movie wraps up
before James gun and Peter saffron opted
against saving the DCU the franchise was
going in a very different direction
following his turn in the flat Michael
Keaton's Batman was set to appear in
Aquaman 2 as well as in the now scrapped
Batgirl movie but other plans were made
there was a time when Aquaman in the
lost kingdom was meant to Premiere
before the events of the Flash and
because of that re-shoot were made to
replace Keaton's Cameo with Ben Affleck
version of the character of course fans
were excited by the news and many had
hoped that the DCU was about to find its
footing again especially after Henry
Cav's way too brief Return of Superman
at the end of black atom and then gun
and saffron came in DC films became DC
Studios and the the DC euu was redcon in
favor of the upcoming DC Universe which
aims to reboot the liveaction franchise
a new with a brand new Batman and
Superman needless to say Batman's Cameo
be it Affleck or Katon is deep
underwater in the first Aquaman we learn
all about young Arthur's journey to
becoming the man who eventually helped
save the world and unite the kingdoms of
Atlantis invaluable in his formation
from a troubled youth to kingly material
is vco who watches out for Arthur
throughout his whole life vco makes his
first official dceu appearance in o
Aquaman where he helps Arthur take the
throne fans may be disappointed to learn
that Willam defo won't be returning his
vco in Aquaman 2 though it's not because
he's off playing the Green Goblin for
Marvel again according to director James
Juan volo's absence is due to a
scheduling conflict Juan revealed to
Entertainment Weekly part of the reason
was because defo schedule did not work
out for us but what that allowed me to
do was expand on Atlanta's role Atlanta
in this one ultimately becomes Arthur's
adviser traditionally vco serves as
Aquaman's faithful adviser in the world
of DC Comics but here on the screen it
seems that Nicole Kidman's Atlanta will
fill that role instead it's fitting
though and allows Arthur and his mother
the much needed FaceTime that they've
been deprived of for so long still it's
sad we won't see defo return in the
first Aquaman it's revealed that there
are Seven Kingdoms of Atlantis as its
King Arthur's quest to unite them is
near the top of his to-do list but we're
a bit fuzzy on what the seventh Kingdom
might actually be Lost Nation had not
yet vanished together they were the
greatest Empire the world had ever seen
of course there's Atlantis itself and we
soon learn of the others which include
zebel the kingdom of the fishermen the
kingdom of the brine the kingdom of the
deserters and the Monstrous trench
though Atlantis zebel the trench and the
deserters were all addressed in the DC
continuity before the 2018 film the
comic book versions of the Final Three
Kingdoms weren't revealed until
afterward in The Echoes of a lifel lived
well Arc the brine is the first being
transplanted into the comics from the
DCU and the kingdom of the rights and
the kingdom of the sea lights followed
the rights are a bunch of underwater
Road while the sea lights are strange
bioluminescent humanoids more than
likely the film will take a completely
different approach in the trailer for
Aquaman in the lost kingdom Arthur and
Mera are married and they have a son of
their own this begs the question if what
we see in the lost kingdom is in line
with what happens in the comics like
anything that deals with Aquaman's comic
book history it's somewhat complicated
but there are clear answers in 1965
Aquaman number 23 hit stores and
aquababy was born that was the actual
nickname for Arthur Curry Jr the
firstborn son of Aquaman and mea
unfortunately the happy family didn't
stay happy forever in Adventure Comics
number 452 Aquaman and Aqualad are
forced into a battle to the death by
Black Manta who uses young Arthur Jr as
leverage as expected Aquaman defeats
Manta but at a terrible price his son is
ultimately killed by the super villain
suffocating as a result of his captivity
this drove a wedge between Aquaman and
mea for decades eventually though
they're able to rekindle and save their
marriage Aquaman has other children too
Aqualad later known as Tempest was
considered Aquaman and meera's adopted
son while AJ was their second child
together years later Arthur also had a
child named corak with an Inuit woman at
some point and in the current DC rebirth
continuity Aquaman and Meera only have a
daughter named andrina also appearing in
the trailer for Aquaman and the lost
kingdom is Black Manta who swore
Vengeance on Aquaman back in the first
movie after the superhero refused to
save his dying father of course the
comic book version of their rivalry is
much darker than that with Aquaman
purposely killing manta's father in
Revenge following his own father's death
additionally recent Comics have revealed
that Manta is actually a long-lost
descendant of the kingdom of the
deserters in the DCU however Manta seems
to be completely human which puts him at
a significant disadvantage when facing
off against a superhero like Aquaman
therefore using Atlantean technology
gifted to him by Ocean Master Manta has
sworn revenge on his adversary but this
time around black manta's abilities have
been upgraded through the use of the
previously unseen black Trident this
magical artifact originates from from
the time of the first king atlan and
seems to give the one who wields it
incredible Powers though it's unlikely a
direct adaptation of either this new
black Trident seems to borrow from two
different weapons from Aquaman's comic
book Adventures the Trident of Triton
and the dead king's scepter Triton's
Trident simply directed the Olympian's
power while the dead King scepter gave
the user control of the sea from what we
see of the black Trident in the trailer
it may even unleash the dead despite
being mentioned elsewhere in the Aquaman
2 trailer Meera only appears once in the
entire thing with a brief Glimpse at her
as she attempts to break into some sort
of underwater craft while it might be
easy to immediately blame her lack of
screen time in the trailer and possibly
the finished film as well on the recent
and very public defamation trial between
Amber herd and her ex-husband Johnny
Depp that might not be the full story
Warner Brothers executive Walter Hamada
said in 2022 Jason mimoa and Amber herd
didn't really have a lot of chemistry
together the reality is it's not
uncommon on movies for two leads to not
have chemistry your majesty there is no
victory in defeating the ignorant
your brother is clearly an
imbecile hamana added that a lot of
their chemistry was developed offset
during post- production making us wonder
how much mea will appear in the Lost
Kingdom at all but according to director
James Juan this was always the plan for
the sequel he explained to Entertainment
Weekly I always pitched this to everyone
from the get-go the first Aquaman was
Arthur and Mira's Journey the second
movie was always going to be Arthur and
orm so the first was a romance action
adventure movie the second one is a
bromance action adventure movie A modern
master of horror Juan Rose to
International Acclaim when he co-created
and directed the first saw back in 2004
the film was so popular that a sequel
was green lit every year for the next 6
years until Saw 3D in 2010 but even then
ju's time with the genre had only just
begun in 2010 Juan directed the first
Insidious which starred future Aquaman
actor Patrick Wilson and spawned a
plethora of sequels a few years later in
2013 Juan directed The Conjuring which
likewise sparked an entire Cinematic
Universe since then he's worked worked
on several other horror movies including
2021s malignant no wonder Juan used his
trademark horror techniques during the
trench sequence in the first Aquaman so
when the trailer for The Lost Kingdom
shows an undead Army controlled by Black
Manta it's no wonder Juan admitted to
adding a certain horror flare back into
the sequel he said at 2020s DC's fandom
event just like the first movie had a
touch of my horror sensibility you know
in regards to the trench sequence I
would say there will be a little bit of
that in this next one following the
release of the first Aquaman in 2018
James Juan announced the development of
a horror infused spin-off centered
around the trench these seed dwelling
beasts first appeared in Jeff John's
Aquaman run during the New 52 Rebrand
and they've since risen to popularity
after appearing in the first film
producer Peter saffron told The
Hollywood Reporter in 2019 we always
even from the early concept art days
loved the idea of a trench movie he
revealed that the trench was meant to
arrive in theaters before Aquaman and
the lost kingdom but only 2 years later
walta Hamada shook things up with the DC
brand aing the project while that was
disappointing poin in news in and of
itself fans became even more
disillusioned after one commented
further that October while showcasing
black manta's New Look for the Lost
Kingdom on Instagram James Juan revealed
something interesting I'll let you in on
a secret the canceled trench spin-off
movie was really going to be a secret
black Mana movie No Doubt fans of the DC
super villain were floored by this news
which only proves that Juan had even
bigger plans for the character and the
greater aquaverse it's too bad the same
couldn't be said about Warner Brothers
with the news that both Batman and super
man would be recast for the DC Universe
reboot and reports that galgadot likely
isn't returning as Wonder Woman it's
understandable that fans would wonder
about the fate of Jason mimo's Aquaman
with DC's biggest hitters being tossed
to the Wayside in favor of new updated
models chances are that the Beloved king
of Atlantis will be next The Flash may
have kept Ezra Miller's Barry Allen and
Jason mima's Arthur Curry around for now
but things could quickly change at least
in mima's eyes there won't be another
Aquaman in the near future speaking with
Variety in 2023 following the news of
James gun and Peter saffron's intention
to reboot the movie Universe he said
I'll always be Aquaman ain't anyone
coming in there and taking there might
be some other characters too I can play
other things too I can be funny and
Savage and Charming with rumors swirling
that mimoa is slated to appear as Lobo
in some point in the near future Peter
saffron told I9 Jason always thought
Aquaman was a Trilogy in his own mind
but he also loves Lobo he's been very
clear about that too he's never going to
play two characters but James gun then
interrupted saffron saying we'll figure
it out after Aquaman 2 for now we'll
just have to wait and see what will
become of mima's Aquaman one of the
biggest questions on fans Minds
concerning Aquaman in the lost kingdom
is whether it will get a followup of its
own more than likely that will depend on
how well the Blockbuster does in
theaters this Christmas but that may not
be the only competing factor in
September of 2023 James Juan told Screen
Rants I'm aware of the impending DCU
reboot I mean I use the analogy that I'm
living in a house that's getting
renovated but the beauty about Aquaman
is that we we've always designed these
two films to be within their own world
given Juan's confidence it's possible
that future installments could go the
way of Matt Reeves out of continuity
project the Batman it could be a viable
way to keep mimoa around but that
doesn't mean the horror turned superhero
director wants to go a third round in
the ring when asked by Entertainment
Weekly if he'd be interested in doing a
third Aquaman film he said oh buddy I
don't know this film has taken up so so
much of my life so much of my time all I
can think about now is taking a long
break one can hardly blame it production
was stalled because of the covid-19
pandemic his Black Manta centered
spin-off the trench was canceled and the
entire DCU went up in flames it's
entirely possible that this could be the
end of Aquaman's on-screen Adventures
though we certainly hope for more while
James Juan might see his Aquaman movies
as their own thing apart from the
greater dceu or DCU it's clear that
Warner Brothers and the folks at DC
Studios don't see it the same way when
asked about the four DC related movies
of 2023 James gun explained how they'll
fit into his larger plan plans revealing
to I9 I think that we've gotten lucky
with the next four movies we have Shazam
which leads into flash which resets
everything which then goes into Blue
Beetle which is totally disconnected and
that goes into Aquaman which leads into
Superman our first big project how
exactly Aquaman and the lost kingdom
connects to a movie like Superman Legacy
is currently unknown the gun helmed
reboot is meant to propel the Man of
Steel into a new universe that also
includes Heroes such as haot girl and
the guy Gardner Green Lantern if there
were to be another sequel it's possible
that it could fit into guns newly minted
DCU especially if he wants this
interpretation of Aquaman to be a
building block for his larger universe
of course given how popular multiverses
are nowadays there's always that Avenue
though it seems that gun wants to stay
away from other worlds for now Superman
Legacy will follow a younger Superman in
an even younger Universe which makes one
wonder how an experienced Aquaman might
fit
[Music]
in